is Nick Gillespie of reason and this is
the reason live stream that we do every
Thursday at 1 pm eastern time I am
joined by my colleague and co-host Zach
weismiller hello hi Zach how you doing
good how are you I'm very good thanks
and we are joined uh today by a very
special guest Eli Lake a national
security reporter
and uh well and goes beyond that who's
been harshly critical of uh the broad
topic that we're talking about today
which has to do with the Durham report
and the investigation into the uh
collusion or so-called collusion between
the Donald Trump presidency and uh the
2016 election or the of Donald Trump in
Russia uh Eli has also recently written
very critically of the FBI which is
front and center in all of this so we're
going to dissect the Durham report uh
talk about what the main findings were
uh what played out what it says about uh
politics in the current moment but uh
especially about the FBI and law
enforcement and intelligence in the
country and what we should be doing next
so Eli thanks for joining it's great to
be here Nick thanks for having me
yeah he's uh Zach is the bad cop so it's
good that
um that you say nice thing so you won't
you won't by the end of it he's gonna be
all over you like a pit bull on a
on a Girl Scout but uh let's start
talking about the uh the Durham report
which was an investigation into the
FBI's investigation into possible
collusion between the Donald Trump
campaign and Russia what do you think is
the you is the core takeaway from the
Durham report
well I think the core takeaway is
um that the people who were leading the
FBI
when uh
in the 90 in the 2016 election which had
investigations into both Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump that that leadership
team starting with Jim Comey and his
Deputy Andrew McCabe
um
we're we're not
honest good cops they were bad cops they
were
fundamentally people of low character
they were willing to
not only deceive the public but they
were willing to keep information from
the elements of the FBI and the legal
system in general such as the
surveillance court and parts of the
justice department
um
that that would somehow you know
undermine their case against or the
theory of a case that they could never
prove about Donald Trump
um
saying that does not mean that you think
that Donald Trump is a good president or
that he should be elected or that uh
there weren't things that Donald Trump
said about Russia that were
unprecedential and bad and that there
were or even that there you know you can
say that and say well you know on the
outside I thought there were things that
were didn't add up in 2016 and maybe
Trump looks suspicious
but the FBI had so much information
uh and they were collecting so much
exculpatory information in the course of
this investigation and then yet they
continued it
the other thing I would say is that
I think it also shows that the real
abuse of power was I think that was
wrongly opened and I think that John
Doran makes a very good case that they
didn't have they didn't have anything
when they opened it in the end of July
of 2016. the investigation has crossed
by a hurricane but the real abuse
was after Trump improbably wins the 2016
election and that's when you really see
the FBI doing all kinds of things to try
to extend this investigation into a
sitting and elected president when they
had nothing and again I mean that's a
it's a it's a testament to the failure
of the leadership of the FBI and that I
would just point out that one of the
things about this report is that John
doorm makes very few actual
recommendations and in part he says he
justifies that I don't have it in front
of me so I'm not going to quote it
verbatim but he basically says you know
if we have leaders of the FBI and you
have people in responsible positions of
the FBI that don't adhere to the motto
of fidelity bravery and integrity well
then it doesn't matter what I recommend
doesn't matter what the org chart look
charred looks like it doesn't matter
what new procedures we might put in
place if you have people who if you have
people of low moral character in these
positions then there's nothing we can do
that's a damning that's a damning thing
to say yeah because every one of these
reports including other damning reports
about the FBI's conduct in this
investigation such as the inspector
General's report Michael Oher they all
include at the end
uh you know we need to have these new
procedures we need to do this and and
and maybe as if there's something you
could fix in the process but sometimes
you just need to sort of say
no you had bad people who were making
bad decisions who were dishonest and
this is what happened and let's make
sure that we don't put in bad people in
these really responsible positions
sounds like kind of obvious thing that
almost anyone could know but it's it's
rare to see that in the in one of these
kind of reports
um we're going to get to uh possible
reforms uh you know Durham doesn't make
them but we can talk about what should
happen to the FBI and then also and on a
bigger picture level how should the
American people uh you know kind of
respond to this like what should we be
thinking about and what should we be
demanding of our government as well as
you know Sub sub parts of that like the
FBI going forward uh just as a quick
starting point before we get into a lot
of the specifics here you know you say
you know this shows that James Comey was
you know had it in for Donald Trump or
was acting unprofessionally you know
going through the 2016 election it you
know the rhetoric and the narrative that
persists is that Comey ruined the
election he tossed the election to Trump
because he screwed over Hillary Clinton
on a nonsense investigation can you just
dispatch that very quickly sure well
first of all let's let's Grant the part
of that narrative that's true
11 days before the election
Jim Comey
announced the reopening of the email
probe
and then we should always remember that
two days before the election he then
announced that it was closed again
and that in the beginning of July of
2016 he announced that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring charges against
Hillary Clinton but what she did was
really bad and was I think she very
Reckless you know his point was
um with her email system now that was
something that
the there was going to have to be
something I mean every it was well known
the FBI was looking into it but it's the
FBI like it it's not like the FBI just
opened it out of I mean this was part of
a
originally a congressional investigation
that started with Benghazi
and then because of Gawker uh it was
discovered I just want to uh interrupt
you to say when you mentioned Benghazi I
feel like uh Lawrence Harvey in the uh
Manchurian Candidate like suddenly I was
triggered and I you know Benghazi is
this term or this you know signifier we
don't talk about it anymore but there
was a multi-year period where it seemed
that every other word out of every other
political figure and pundit was Benghazi
but please continue no that's that
that's that's for for those who don't
remember
you're lucky it's when the U.S consulate
in Libya
was overrun by a group of terrorists and
the response from the Obama
Administration initially was that it was
uh social media flash mob that got out
of hand in response to a movie on
YouTube about the prophet Muhammad
anyway yeah so
Gawker at first published emails that
were taken by this hacker that went by
the name of Gucci for 2.0
that from Sydney Blumenthal okay so
those then revealed that Clinton had a
private email address that apparently
she was using when she was the Secretary
of State can Congress gets all over this
they subpoena all this stuff
Hillary Clinton's Tech
uh who was running this private
homebrews server
then deletes a bunch of back emails it
later was determined that it was not
nefarious or at least the FBI determined
that they didn't do it for any bad
reasons but
um so then there were this uh this
question of will we subpoenaed all of
your archives because you were the
Secretary of State using a private email
server
but then somebody deleted it so then it
becomes like well did you obstruct our
investigation now this is all happening
in Congress but FBI doesn't really have
much of a choice it has to sort of look
into it especially since
you know and people made this point at
the time if you were using a private
email server and you were I don't know
like a mid-level state department or
mid-level defense department person you
probably would be at the very least
fired and there may even be
um litigation you know you you might you
might face you know criminal penalties
because there are strict rules about
what kind of information you're allowed
to put on unencrypted devices and so
forth so there's a whole question or a
lingering Scandal about Hillary Clinton
that has nothing to do with what the FBI
says or doesn't say
that is before the 2016 election season
really and sort of going into it and it
looks like it's going to be the main
Republican attack line which is was the
Secretary of State use um using a
private unprotected email system
to basically you know communicate
sensitive or classified information
and
um what the that was what the FBI was
basically looking at and what the FBI
said was well you know is a good chance
that foreign governments may have gotten
a hold of it but no reasonable
prosecutor would really prosecute
Hillary Clinton so in some ways you
could argue that the initial press
conference from Comey was a good thing
for Hillary Clinton if you remember
the first response from Trump at the
time was to attack James Comey and to
say they were compromised on the other
hand the press conference was a little
bit of a split at the baby approach
because Hillary Clinton was done the
less criticized for her private email uh
server I would just say one thing at
this point I am somebody who believes
that there's way too much emphasis on
protecting too many secrets in the US
government and at the time I didn't
think it was something that ought to
have disqualified Hillary Clinton from
running and especially since she'd
already gotten the nomination from her
party so I didn't think that an FBI
investigation or a justice department
prosecution uh was warranted that would
have basically negated the choice of the
democratic party for their nomination
that year
but it's not like the FBI or people who
were bringing up as a criticism of
Hillary Clinton her use of this private
email server you know this line but her
emails right it's not like they were
making a mountain out of them all I mean
it was a fair criticism in my view yeah
why did she use this private email
server but so that's the background of
this that's the argument for why the FBI
sabotaged her but what we learned from
the dorm report is that there were
several investigations I should say
there were I think there were three
separate investigations that were
started in some way
um and they weren't even full
investigations but there was information
was coming in that looked at foreign
governments trying to influence Hillary
Clinton or her campaign in two of those
cases Hillary received what's known as a
defensive briefing so she was told we
we've picked up this information be on
the lookout for any donations from
country X
um in another city in one of these
investigations
there was uh the field office had asked
for surveillance warrants and they never
got uh they never replied for those
surveillance warrants because
headquarters basically didn't act on the
request
um and then there were separately in
addition to all of that there were three
field office investigations by the
beginning of 2016 into the Clinton
Foundation that is the
big charitable organization that Clinton
set up and they would solicit donations
not only from Big corporations but from
foreign governments even when Clinton
Hillary Clinton was the Secretary of
State or when she was a Senator and so
um some of this was based on Peter
schweitzer's book called Clinton cash
Peter Schweitzer you know the criticism
over the left is the Peter Schweitzer is
a partisan but that doesn't mean
everything that he wrote was wrong and
also it was a separate it was one thing
in one strand in a investigation anyway
Andrew McCabe
um slow rolled the Clinton Foundation
investigations in 2016. what did he do
he he tried to consolidate them into one
field office he told them no over
investigative steps without my approval
that was basically hamstringing them
then there was
um in addition to that there was a phone
call from Jim Jim comey's office telling
the cease and desist investigation
altogether based on an unidentified
counterintelligence tip all of this is
in the dorm report all of it is
fairly new and I should say it relates
to something else which is that Andrew
McCabe was just chastised for lying to
investigators in a leak investigation so
this is the inspector General's another
Inspector General report
um and you know what what he was what he
did was he leaked you know he talked to
the Wall Street Journal about a story
about these Clinton Foundation
investigations
and made it seem like basically to and
and basically put this on the justice
department saying the justice department
didn't want to do anything about it
trying to obscure his own role in
slowing it down and why is that
important because his wife ran for
Statewide office or I guess for a State
Delegate office in Virginia and had
received money from Terry McAuliffe
who's close to the clintons so there was
potentially a sort of conflict of
interest for the deputy FBI director and
all this and and he but the but I would
say that you specifically
um really chastised by the Inspector
General
for lying about talking to the Wall
Street Journal claiming he didn't and
then pinning it on an underling who did
who he had instructed so he was
basically shoving it off on someone who
was lower in the pecking order than he
was
and
um you know he didn't really face any
consequences of that for that we don't
want to go down so we don't want to get
into why but we're going to get into
McDonald's
my point is that is that like
you know all of this stuff is relevant
and so what dorm concludes with this is
that
there were two standards for opening
investigations and dealing with
investigations into the two campaigns
which is if for the Clinton staff you
you know that there there was you know
they did everything they could to keep
it from becoming a new investigation and
they slow rolled stuff and for Trump if
you look at what ultimately was
the reason for opening this huge
investigation it's a joke it is a joke
and it's really important that we make
this clear to everybody that the initial
reason for this investigation which was
a memo from the Australian Ambassador
and some other Australian diplomats
to the U.S embassy which then goes to
the FBI
um was not information it was pure like
speculation and finally after all of
these years we actually see the relevant
what's called paragraph five the part of
the Australian cable that's relevant to
the opening of the crossfire hurricane
and you could read it for yourself it's
it's there's no information it says
there was a suggestion from this another
a junior campaign
volunteer named George papadale was not
a senior figure somebody who just
happened to be in a wine bar with
Australian diplomats and they're having
a random conversation and then the
Australians then report this after the
news of the um hack of the DNC emails
comes out right he doesn't say
we we know that the Russians are going
to hack
you know the emails from Democrats he
doesn't say anything like that he just
simply says there's a lot of baggage
that Hillary has and we know we have a
lot of stuff I think we're going to win
you know the Russians might do something
and so it's so the information is
conveyed as
a suggestion
that the Russians might it's like a
suggestion of a suggestion right it
doesn't it there's no specifics no
mention of emails no mention of whether
Trump knew anything about or anybody
else of the campaign knew anything about
it
and so
if what Durham basically is saying is if
that's all you had why didn't you
check with the Russia analysts in the
FBI why don't you check with other
people in the intelligence Community why
didn't you interview the diplomats why
didn't you interview George Papadopoulos
why don't you do all these things
before opening a full investigation in
the middle of an election of the
Republican nominee the Republican
campaign why why would and that's and
because that's like it's like crazy to
think that that was the reason why they
launched it but the Australians do they
send the memo after the leak of the DNC
correct yeah okay so they're kind of
putting it together and saying oh this
must be what George Papa docs right but
then correct but then what dorm says is
that and because he interviews everybody
the reason it took so long is he just he
he did all of the work he did the work
he read his Bell hooks he's an ally yeah
he's an ally right
um
so he interviewed Alexander Downer the
The Ambassador in London and he said he
didn't remember anything about emails he
didn't remember anything about whether
or not Georgetown Papadopoulos said that
Trump knew about it or was willing so
that's the one thing and the second
thing is
and I found this amazing because I
always thought
there had to be something more to it
um so he looked in throughout the entire
US government state department CIA NSA
he he had the full access and he wanted
to find out
was there anything in your Holdings
meaning had you collected any
information
that would have supported the theory
that Trump was in a culusary
relationship with Russia where his
campaign was and they had nothing not
the FBI not the state department no one
in the U.S and the vast U.S intelligence
Community for which Russia has been
if not the number one target the number
two target for the last 70 years so we I
mean we're talking about like trillions
of dollars worth of like you know over
the years of in of collection
infrastructure aimed at you know one
target or a few a few one of a few
targets nothing they had nothing
yeah it was just a cable that was based
on a suggestion of a suggestion now if
you're to tell me that you still think
it was okay for the FBI to I mean again
it's not like they launched it's not an
investigation into
some Rando and it doesn't matter this is
It's it really matters if you and then
by the way because it's a full
investigation as opposed to what he said
would would have been a preliminary
investigation or even what he or an
assessment so there's all these other
steps that we're learning about that you
do in the FBI it means that they can
send
uh confidential human sources and you
know snitches they can send moles into
meeting with people for the Trump
campaign to try to solicit information
from them you know where they
surreptitiously where they don't know
they're talking to somebody who's going
to go right to the FBI
they do that
and then what do they get back they get
back I don't know what you're talking
about we don't we're not talking any
Russians we'd never change so Not only
was the investigation started on the
flimsy of pretext it did not it did not
yield it was a bad hunch
Not only was it a bad hunch the only
information that the FBI gets that would
confirm this initial suspicion from this
one cable well it's the steel dossier
right
which uh we now know Oppo research uh on
Trump that essentially its Origins were
with the Hillary Clinton campaign she
paid for it yes yeah so that you have
and by the way they lied about it yeah
they lied about it to the FEC and they
lied about it and the lawyer Mark Elias
lied about it for eight months Zach I
mean this this new information that's
come forth in the report that you
referenced with regards to
the Slow Rolling of Investigations into
the Clinton Foundation or these foreign
donations that either in one case was
not investigated at all the other this
defensive briefing was given it raises
the question for a lot of people
including someone in our audience who
will bring up here of whether this is
political bias uh Rex Sauls asks does
the Durham report give Credence to the
FBI whistleblowers about bias against
conservatives in government on the other
hand there was the inspector General's
report that said there this there were
problems with the investigation but
there was no evidence of political bias
and if we look at what McCabe said well
that's that's not what the Inspector
General said okay could you please uh
the Inspector General said is that he
didn't find evidence of it yes but he
didn't clear them of it because he he
also said okay
the explanation for all of these errors
particularly when he's talking about the
fisa process
doesn't wash so he didn't find like
another explanation for why all the
errors went in One Direction against
Trump right but what he found was he he
didn't have a like a Smoking Gun he
didn't have an interview with somebody
where they said well you know I'm a
Democrat and I just really loved Hillary
Clinton and so I did all this stuff so
he didn't get that but he didn't get
anything that made sense to him that
could explain why they made so many
errors in the same direction and like
then you add that to what dorm has
discovered where they just there were
all these things they didn't consider
there are all these lines of
investigation that they didn't even try
so like there was there were there were
people who were lower down in the FBI
for example this is a very important
point and what this wasn't by the way in
the Horowitz report he didn't get into
this there were people lower down that
said because the steel dossier was taken
extremely seriously by the FBA not just
for the fisa court there is a kind of a
kind of little rhetorical maneuver that
has been done by some of the Dead Enders
on russiagate which is to try to suggest
that the steel dossier was very
insignificant to the overall
investigation actually it was really
important in the investigation so there
were there were people this is when we
have the Mueller report there were FBI
agents who were looking at it and they
said we should start an investigation
into someone named Charles Dolan Charles
Dolan is a long time Clinton Ally
who was at the time an unregistered
foreign agent for Russia who dorum says
is probably responsible for the is the
origin of the p-tape lie as well as
other things that ended up in the
dossier and also he charged The Remains
the sub Source the main collector in the
dossier guy named Igor danchenko which I
hope we can talk about a little bit yes
with lying about his relationship with
Dolan
he was acquitted of those uh five counts
of of uh Lying by the way but we should
just say
um so this so the FBI guys wanted to
investigate Charles Dolan
because he was somebody who it looks
like who had contributed to the Steele
dossier who clearly wasn't a Russian
official was that's not intelligence
he's a spin doctor that is actually
working for the Russians so and a big
time Democrat okay and then that was you
know and and the the leadership of the
of the Mueller team
said no we're not going to investigate
him yeah so it raises this why you know
there was so you didn't pursue any leads
that weren't part of
um the you know theory that Trump and
his campaign colluded
um you ignored evidence and you didn't
share the evidence with the right people
that were as exculpatory on that
and even after you got dead end after
dead end you kept this investigation
going so those are like I mean so answer
the question was it politicized it may
not have been politicized in the sense
of
um everybody at the at the FBI I mean
like I think Peter Struck it you know
for many years as was Comey voted for
Republicans it wasn't like a Republicans
versus Democrats or something like that
but it was certainly politicized against
Trump yeah certainly like people had
anti-trump bias that's what I yeah what
I'm trying to understand better is the
motivations of the key decision makers
um and it's you can kind of
start to see some of it when you look in
detail at the report like I pulled this
section from this is this is the portion
uh where they're talking about the
investigation into a four uh an illegal
foreign
donation to The Clinton campaign from
some unnamed foreign government and this
is where they gave a defensive briefing
to Hillary's team but hey we're looking
into this and this is what McCabe had to
say about it according to Durham uh he
said that uh you know when we take
defensive briefings or when we do
defensive briefings we have to take into
account whether it will eliminate or
reduce your ability to get to the bottom
of the threat
um another uh assistant director for
counterintelligence said that because
the possibility existed that someone on
the Trump campaign could have already
taken the Russians up on their offer I
thought it was wise to open an
investigation to look into the situation
um and that presumably a defensive
briefing would undermine that
investigation so you know and then later
on you know Durham raises the point well
wouldn't that logic equally and also
work for Clinton campaign but does it
can I ask yeah sure oh I was just going
to say uh you know Zach and Eli you know
the difference here is that Hillary
Clinton was the Secretary of State and
she had she would have been a U.S
senator and she had credibility I mean
she had worked on the government Etc
yeah whereas Donald Trump was a kind of
loose cannon nobody really knew what he
was talking about his son had said
various things he had said various
things I mean I and I'm playing devil's
advocate here yeah like you you know
Trump you uh Trump has a long history of
payouts and and you know lawsuits Etc
and Shady business dealings I could see
why I would be like I'm not going to
tell Trump we're looking into this
because he's is going to immediately you
know react in a way that would destroy
evidence is that not I mean legitimate I
would agree with you if this was like
another political figure if it was like
Frank church or something
it's Hillary Clinton and I'm not trying
to be difficult what I'm trying to say
is we know from lots of things that the
Clinton Foundation had all kinds of pay
for play operations going on so our
argument yeah your argument is that like
is that like I don't see any evidence
that like Clinton would somehow I mean I
agree with you yeah she was Secretary of
State and I'm not necessarily accusing
her of anything but Bill Clinton gave
lots of speeches for you know six
figures I think you know fees like
Russian Banks to Kazakhstan okay but so
your your argument is not that they
should have given a defensive briefing
to Trump it's that they should not have
given a defensive brief brief my
argument is that there's a double
standard that's a double standard okay
okay um fair enough because I could
argue with the other way too which is to
say that like well you know I mean
I I agree that like if you just were
looking at what Trump was saying
particularly about Russia and his
behavior in general
it raised certain Flags when he sort of
couldn't answer the question straight
about whether he thought Nader was a
good idea and things like that yeah but
we don't live in a country where
you are cast Under Suspicion yeah or
investigated because of an opinion that
you bring into the debate no matter how
out of left field it is yeah and it's
not Elite that's in fact undermines our
Democratic process I mean we have had a
so-called consensus I am a believer in
the consensus by the way that NATO is
good and Russian Russia is a rogue a
rogue actor and really bad or whatever
Trump disagreed he's running for
president it's like for the voters to
decide basically but you can't say I'm
not going to give him a defensive
briefing because of things that he's
illegally protected to say under the
First Amendment and are part of our
Democratic process right okay fair
enough um you know the other thing that
I wanted to bring up when when this is
going on by this point have the uh have
has the DNC emails been hacked
and released because that also seems to
feed into it it's not directly relevant
to Hillary's email servers and stuff
because but that seemed to be or it was
very quickly talked about as a function
of Russian interference into the
election that uh guccifer guccifer
uh
you know had a 2.0 had hacked the emails
and right they really showed a rotten
element in the DNC that among other
things besides the fact of being hacked
and looking like idiots that the um the
DNC was really working to throw the uh
primary process to Hillary Clinton
does that have any bearing on any of
this stuff
um well they were I don't know that you
needed
um I mean there's an argument that yeah
that's kind of like
what I political parties you know you
tend to also and this is the first time
this has happened so sometimes the left
makes it seem like a bigger Scandal than
it really is right
um but certainly Hillary had her allies
in the DNC but I mean that that happens
a lot you know where there's an Insider
candidate who's going to have that kind
of Advantage the second thing I would
say is that it was the hack of the
podesta emails
um did reveal some extraordinary things
um such as the like internal
correspondence on the Clinton Foundation
um yeah it was the Clinton Foundation
where like uh Chelsea Clinton was saying
I can't believe you guys are you know
you're such gone UPS you know like what
are you doing here you're you're
charging it like you know you're double
booking and charging all the stuff and
like you know Clinton was clear there
were all kinds of kind of paybacks
involved which is supposed to be the
sort of charitable stuff and there's a
really devastating
a couple emails on that and then there
was another hack of her speeches that
she gave to Goldman Sachs that Bernie
Sanders was all talking about now
I think this gets into a really
important point that has been missed in
the first part of the 2000 teens up to
probably 2016 it was totally normal for
journalists to use hacked materials if
there was a public interest value class
example would be cable gate from
Wikileaks right we saw this with uh
there was a great kind of victory for
the remember the the there was the the
climate change emails that were that
that was that showed the corruption of
you know so there were all kinds of
stories like that and nobody sort of
said what did you what would you
couldn't print that or releasing that
information was really bad because it
was hacked by somebody even though it
was and no as long as it was true it was
true right exactly right come on like
why why are we talking about how we got
it this these are meaningful documents
yeah so the you know so the Russians did
hack these emails and this information
but it was true and right some of it was
news now that standard changes after the
2016 election again I I can argue with
both ways maybe it was good that it
changed okay but
um you can't hold the Trump people
to account for not for for playing by
the standards that everybody played by
in 2016 that then changes after the 2016
election right so oftentimes now I mean
I I look at this as the the I call them
the Russia gate dead Enders whatever you
want to say but what they're doing is
what's known as retconning because they
they started with this idea that Clinton
I'm sorry the Trump colluded with Russia
it didn't pan out Weller didn't find any
evidence of it so they're now clinging
to other pieces of information saying no
no no see this adds up to that yeah and
it and so that's part about it but like
you know well Roger Stone was trying to
get the emails Yeah Yeah from Wikileaks
are you surprised yeah of course that
doesn't have anything to do ultimately
with the facts that we know them this is
the broader context of a lot of this
stuff is you know that russiagate has
emerged as you know the idea that the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government are elements in the Russian
government and elements of the Trump
campaign were colluding in a way that
was nefarious real and effective and
it's just there is no evidence for any
of that but people are acting as if it
still is in play despite they're acting
as if it's true if it was obviously true
right and that you are denying reality
if you if you if you if you insist on
that is that these reports or whatever
say it's not true Let's uh you know what
let's let's look at the uh Zach let's uh
pull up the McCabe Clips because McCabe
is uh Andrew McCabe the deputy director
of the FBI
um is is really a point person and Eli
we want you to look at these clips and
then kind of react yeah can I just make
a quick plug my podcast the re-education
yes I hope you subscribe too uh Nick has
been a guest twice for some classic
episodes
um
my latest episode is is just about
Andrew McCabe and uh the fact that he's
still that's one of the reasons that
we're having you on here your your
coverage of this but yeah
Eli's yeah 30-minute monologue kind of a
documentary an essay a kind of you know
Andrew McCabe you are a horrible human
being it's much more profound than that
but let's look at these McKay clips and
then uh Eli tell us what you're thinking
yeah this is like a political version of
Two Girls One Cup this is going to be a
response video uh just to set these up
the the first clip is from 2019 so this
is after Cabe uh McCabe has been
dismissed from the FBI and he is on a
book tour and I think it he's having
conversation with uh Anderson Cooper and
I think it reveals a little bit of his
mind set the mindset of the people at
the very top of uh you know the
investigation about how they were
thinking about this how this was going
to play out so Adam go ahead and play
that clip for us
not just one not just two but numerous
people in and around the president in
and around the campaign maintained
contacts with individuals from Russia
people connected to the Russian
intelligence Services you have a number
who have been charged a number who've
been already convicted and pled guilty
for all kinds of different offenses do
you still believe the president could be
a Russian asset
I think it's possible I think that's why
we started our investigation and I'm
really anxious to see where director
Mueller concludes that
and then this next clip is just from
last week so clearly his you know his
belief that Trump might have been a
Russian asset in early 2019 has not been
borne out whatsoever but uh now he's
being asked on CNN about his reaction to
the Durham report is someone who's named
in it hundreds of times let's talk about
it with CNN senior law enforcement
analyst Andy McCabe he's a former deputy
director of the FBI and importantly he
oversaw what became known as a crossfire
hurricane probe into Trump in 2016. John
Durham says that you shouldn't have
launched it what's your response
John Durham is wrong and it's not just
me that says that every other entity
that's investigated
um our our activities in 2016 agrees and
that's of course as you mentioned uh the
doj uh Inspector General Michael
Horowitz as well as the Senate
intelligence committee LED of course uh
at the time by a republican uh
so this is
this report poppy stands as an anomaly
so Eli what's your reaction to now CNN's
uh senior legal analyst Andrew McCabe's
assertion that this is just an outlier
and everyone else says that the
investigation was pretty much Justified
well
you know and now uh let's turn um now
that we're talking about the danger to
children right now
um at clown parties let's turn to our
senior analyst John Wayne Gacy
um tell us what do you think about this
new Crackdown on child abuse and are you
serious this is I'm just I I I know I
should I should we know it's there but
like yeah
on previous streams it's uh fairly
disturbing but uh putting that aside
okay the substance
um so first of all we should just point
out Andrew McCabe did not elect to talk
to John Durham and yet he is here
talking to CNN so that's what so okay if
you really think you're if you really
think it's all just a big persecution
that's that's a tell second of all he's
wrong it's not anomaly
um Michael horowitz's report in 2019
um is devastating to the FBI
um the FBI itself in responses dorm
report said
we take it very seriously and we've
already put reforms in place and the
people who are responsible for this no
longer work for us
so I mean I was paraphrasing there but
so so the the FBI itself doesn't think
it's an anomaly
um you know and
I guess the other point is that you know
that first clip he's making that a you
know late February 2019 he's talking to
Anderson Cooper uh we would learn in a
few months
that the baller team found no evidence
of a trump-russia conspiracy and then we
would learn by the end of the year that
the FBI had deceived and gained the
surveillance Court the fisa court and
that um it wasn't an isolated incident
and you know we would learn all kinds of
other things about this investigation so
what the hell is the former FBI deputy
director talking about when he says he
thinks that the president of the United
States might be
a foreign agent which is basically I
mean you are you are that is John Birch
Society level invective
from the other direction and it's coming
from the FBI and there was no evidence
and he knew there was no evidence for it
when he was making those remarks there
were no evidence when he was like when
he was fired from the FBI of that and
the I mean the arrogance and the fact
that it's like you're pouring you're
it's it's a kind of like at some I mean
listen I don't go in for the
disinformation talk that everyone's
talking about
but if you want an example of
disinformation
Andrew McCabe in his interview with
Anderson Cooper that's disinformation
and he knew better that's the thing it's
like listen I forgive other analysts for
saying in 2017 it looks like Trump has
something to hide I thought Trump had
something to hide I when he fired Comey
in the way he did there was a lot of
information the public didn't have
so I mean that's that happens that you
know life you know there's but the
people at the FBI who are who are
running the investigation they have far
more information than us as it should be
so for them to then become like public
pundits or something and then
use that their positions to create a
false kind of Scandal or false crisis in
American democracy it's despicable there
and it's unbelievable to me that he's
still an analyst for CNN how could you
be some how could you be on the the
journalism side of a news Outlet as some
sort of analyzing the news he's he
should be the target of a hostile
interview you know I mean like you
should he should be like you know Jake
Tapper should should do his whole thing
by the way Jake Tapper is very good on
the dorm report I should say
um I want to credit him for that and
there's a lot of you know but you know
when Jake Tapper was saying I made a new
rule We're not gonna have any
Republicans on they're gonna lie about
the 2020 election okay great can we have
a rule We're not gonna have anybody
who's gonna lie about the 2017
investigation into Trump including our
our own senior law enforcement analyst
so I I just find it incredible that he's
still an analyst and he's not the only
one I don't want to pick on Andrew
McCabe all of these people it's
particularly true with CNN and really
MSNBC I mean half their roster seems to
be these former yeah
yeah it's uh I I to rebuild their
credibility I really would like to see
an editorial policy go into place that
you just don't hire former Intel
officials to be commentators for you it
doesn't well it seems I should say if if
if he's if you have on just a generic
former senior FBI person as a news
analyst because I don't know we we there
was a terrorist attack or something yeah
I mean that's fine that person is going
to have perspective on how
investigations work is probably going to
have some old contacts
it's when there is a the story is the is
is is the bad behavior from the FBI you
can't then have these people on as like
news analysts yeah it's the bad
behaviors that they that they did you
know yeah and and you mentioned I mean
the idea that you know the
disinformation narrative kind of like
flipping and now it is the in the Intel
agents like putting out the
disinformation to the American people I
mean there is a very interesting little
moment in the Durham report that I've
pulled up here you you mentioned uh e
Garden chenko uh earlier uh and what
they say about him who this is the sub
source for the Steele dossier and
apparently uh dentchenko may have had
some links to Russian intelligence
Services the FBI had investigated him
before and not really resolved that
issue and what uh Durham says about this
is is that in not resolving danchenko
status vis-a-vis the Russian
intelligence Services it appears the FBI
never gave appropriate consideration to
the possibility that the intelligence
denchenko was providing to steal which
again according to denchenko himself
made up a significant majority of the
information in the steel dossier dossier
reports was in fact was in whole or in
part Russian disinformation so there's a
very disturbing irony there that the for
all the talk of Russian disinformation
the most impactful piece might have been
purveyed by the FBI I mean what was your
reaction to reading that section of the
report well I mean or the Clinton
campaign in this case the Clinton
campaign kind of filtered it to the FBI
yeah
can't make it up
I mean hilarious right
um it's not by the way that's not the
only that's not even the worst of it I
mean
um Christopher Steele himself as well as
the
firm that hired him Fusion GPS
were working for
Russian oligarch Oleg deripaska
Oleg daropaska is the aluminum magnate
bad guy
um but Oleg darapaska is the big
connection that is always talked about
in context of Paul manafort who was also
a bad guy who was briefly the uh for
like two months he was the campaign
manager for the Trump uh campaign
um
well here's like steel who is presenting
himself as this you know former British
spy who's you know trying to stop the
Russians and doing whatever he can
on how to side deal working with
deripaska to try to retrieve money that
was owed to him by Paul manafort
so I mean one would think that's the FBI
ought to know that and that would then
affect the credibility of the dossier
and they wouldn't submit it as evidence
in a
um fisa application fisa warrant
application for Carter page but again
that's just part of this whole pattern
that dorm exposed which is that all
these steps that you think would be
obvious that they would take
um to try to confirm information and all
kinds of things like that they didn't
take
so again there's so many errors that at
a certain point
from my perspective it's no longer a
question of wow you're such an
incompetent boobs like it's no it's like
I think it was corrupt at a certain
point so too many there's too many
mistakes right and they're always going
in the same direction always you know
having said this and we've talked about
this in different contexts Eli uh both
separately and together but you know the
longer you look at the history of the
FBI and when you read something like Tim
Weiner's book or the Beverly gauge uh
biography of Jagger Hoover I actually uh
am more drawn to the uh you know to the
hypothesis or the thesis that the FBI is
simply a corrupt not a corrupt
organization a fundamentally incompetent
one
um but we're going to get to that more
in a second of what what do we do with
the FBI after this let's talk a little
bit about how Trump intersects with all
of this both in terms of his behavior
that made a lot of people wonder what
the [__] is going on but also his
reaction to the Durham report and I do
want to point out just very quickly that
John Durham to me you know it's ironic
that he is investigating Crossfire
hurricane because that sounds to me like
a Doobie Brothers song and he looks like
he could be in he could be the third
bassist
the lyric from a Rolling Stones uh I
know that but it's I think it's a Doobie
Brothers thing yes yeah but he doesn't
think he could be a doobie brother or
like Dr Hook and the medicine show yeah
something like that you know or playing
at a local bar yeah or a blues mother
cover band uh let's uh Zach cue up the
uh the Trump clips that you want to run
oh okay
foreign
okay so this uh this first one is just
uh generally this is one piece of
evidence that people point to to say
well Trump kind of had it coming he in
fact openly colluded like regardless of
how these investigations turned out we
have evidence on tape that he openly
colluded and here is the Smoking Gun
he didn't even wasn't behind closed
doors it was open that Trump invited and
demanded that Rush occlude and uh Eli in
your uh wonderful uh most recent episode
of the re-education you talk about how
uh a great journalist like Jonathan
Roush points to this or or says Trump on
occasions openly invited the Russians to
meddle in the election this is the clip
that we're talking about let's let's run
this thing what do I have to get
involved with Putin if I have nothing to
do with putting enough talking to him I
don't know anything about him other than
he will respect me he doesn't respect
our president
and if it is Russia which is probably
not nobody knows who it is but if it is
Russia
it's really bad for a different reason
because it shows how little respect they
have for our country when they would
hack into a major party
and get everything
but it would be interesting to see I I
will tell you this Russia if you're
listening I hope you're able to find the
30 000 emails that are missing
I think you will probably be rewarded
mightily by our press
was that collusion
the dead to rights
get them in an orange jumpsuit Rock
March them out
that's it you know where's the justice
department
yeah we've cracked the code
really really have you never seen this
guy before I mean it's like he's a
nightclub comedian who happened to be
like PR I mean he's this is all like his
patter in some ways and it seems to me I
mean maybe I'm wrong but I interpreted
that as saying I don't have anything to
do with the Russians by the way that was
wrong when he said that
um his fixer Mike Cohen was trying to uh
arrange a deal that never happened to
build a Trump Tower in Moscow okay and
then he says uh you know it would be
really bad uh if it was the Russians
because it shows how little respect
which is true it does show how little
respect they have to the United States
and then uh you know he's then talking
about
the missing emails that were the was the
the kind of prevailing narrative at the
time which was well what she deleted all
these emails and they didn't charged
attack or anybody else and like it's not
unfair and you know what was in those
emails that was so you know there must
have been something so devastating that
they got rid of them which also is not
sure it's not clear right well it's yeah
it's it's it's like that if you wanna
that it's kind of that that's a that's a
little bit of an innuendo kind of attack
too on the other hand
um again I look at it as a matter of
sort of double standards if somebody in
the Trump campaign even if it was a
junior junior chipmunk like a George
Papadopoulos had deleted information
that was subpoenaed by Congress do you
really think everybody would be like oh
who cares what a then that's not a big
deal I didn't do it for corrupt reasons
so
um but anyway that's what he was that's
what he was getting at he was like well
you know you can find them and I can and
we now know because of the Mueller
report that there really was Trump was
obsessed with finding those emails so he
contracted people to you know he asked
Mike Flynn to go find them and I think
there were people who were willing to go
try to get them from anyone but that is
not and it doesn't have anything to do
with what the Russians actually did they
hacked the DNC and they hacked John
podesta and they gave us it was separate
emails they're both emails but it's
different things and
um again I don't I I don't think I'll
ever convince David from or Jonathan
Roush or
law fair or you know Ben with us I'm
probably never going to convince them
that this is like what is this like how
how is that count of any of anything but
they I mean it was certainly say we also
know I mean listen when this started and
people thought that Trump was gonna get
nailed by Mueller so for the nobody said
in those first two and a half years of
the Trump years like hey they already
got him look what he said in July 27th
you know 2016. right right it's right
there on tape why do we have to do any
more investigating that's collusion
everybody no they thought they were
going to find but you know was described
in the steel dossier well-developed
conspiracy and like Paul manafort and
Michael Cohen and Prague and all this
other stuff none of it true uh was all
you mentioned uh just briefly George
Papadopoulos and Mike Flynn
um let's talk a little bit about the uh
you know the band of idiots that Trump
surrounded himself with or who were
working for him including Paul manafort
who is a bad guy and why is also a bad
campaign manager at least for Trump uh
you know he's he's in jail uh but
yeah yeah
um he was convicted though uh you know
he was not convicted for anything having
to do with Russia so there's a lot of
people who got convicted like manafort's
convicted
right and other things that have nothing
to do with absolutely is bad again a
friend to autocrats you know everywhere
as long you know in order to help them
win fake elections right
um but somebody like George Papadopoulos
what does it say I mean is there any
blame on Trump that he surrounded
himself with a bunch of incompetence who
were doing things like having you know
the conversation that Papadopoulos had
in Australia or with the Australians or
is that simply it wouldn't have mattered
that I would have maybe said I would
have maybe been more sympathetic to that
point but after looking at the actual
memo and what the conversation was I
just don't he was a young guy he was a
volunteer
he this is really like he he had another
meeting with his Professor named mifsud
who was you know a Maltese guy who
seemed to have connections to Russia
um he's described as a Russian asset a
Russian he's connected to Russian
intelligence in the Mueller report
um it's interesting he was interviewed
once he was never subpoenaed sort of
disappeared we don't know what happened
to him
um I'm not saying he's dead I'm just
saying we haven't heard from him and
it's sort of this one weird loose end
but we also know that nothing came of
whatever this theory about what
Papadopoulos was into because then what
should have what should have the FBI
done in your mind to under the
circumstances where Papadopoulos this
low level
uh foreign policy advisor for Trump
meets with this weird Shady professor
and then tells the Australian diplomats
that there's some sort of Russian data
dump coming or something he didn't say
there was a Russian data dump the point
is he said I I don't know
that the Russians might have something
it was a suggestion of a suggestion I
have to I have to get it in front of me
at least the actual test is really
really revealing is my point okay so
that he makes some sort of suggestion
the Australian authorities report it
right after the Russians do dump
something what is what would a more
competent or less corrupt FBI do under
those circumstances well I think we got
into a little bit before but what and
I'm just based on someone to him
check the rest of the intelligence
Community you have any information to
support this interview the Australian
diplomats first to say Hey What Can you
tell us more about this this is
fascinating maybe even interview George
Papadopoulos why not I mean I there's no
I mean do they have anything like on him
that suggests he's somehow dirty is he
so it's like if he's not on your list if
you don't have any reason to think that
he's somebody and I don't think they did
why don't you just call him in and
straight up ask him yeah
um what about uh what about people like
Mike Flynn uh you know okay so Mike
Flynn who's uh you know going to be
Trump's National Security advisor his
the denuma of his post Trump uh you know
appointment does not I mean it's it does
he cuts a very disturbing figure right
now he seems to be either certifiably
insane or you know just batshit crazy on
some level did Mike Flynn bring problems
to the Trump campaign by the way that he
acted and the way that he talked well
there is so
there was nothing other than the fact
that Mike Flynn went you know appeared
on RT and got money from our team I
think got money from like some other
speaking fee okay right you could have
invested they in fact the FBI did
investigate this and they found nothing
and they were ready to close the
investigation
uh like before the end of the election
and the lead got I mean we have all that
right to right
um there was also you know Mike Flynn
had a lobbying contract which is not
uncommon people who are
advisors or surrogates in a campaign
will have other kinds of influence
contracts that they have it's how people
make money when they leave government
um so he had another contract uh for a
businessman who was a cut out for the
Turkish government to defame
um fatula gulen
uh who is a a rival of President erdogan
right okay so it's a sleazy contract
that he had and he had filed it under a
looser law known as the lobbying
disclosure act as opposed to foreign
agents registration Act
um that was fairly common before 2017
for people to do that if they were
representing a think tank or a business
as opposed for a direct contract to a
foreign government and he was following
the advice of his attorney but and and
by the way as soon as Trump wins and
he's going to be the National Security
advisor he ends the contract right
um maybe you know he there's a whole
bunch of things he could have done so
that was all like interesting I guess
and it was a thing totally fair game for
the media Chuck Ross I think broke that
story first
um so all that is like interesting uh
but there was no Russia connection with
flan and the FBI knew there was no
Russian connection and then they tried
to
make it seem like maybe they missed
something because in the transition he
called the Russian Ambassador or the
Russian Ambassador tried to call him
and we never knew what was this phone
call was until 2020.
so there was it so for a long time
people thought well they had they must
have had a transcript they they
overheard a phone call with the Russian
Ambassador and it must have been so bad
because that was enough to try to well
then we finally saw the transcript for
this and I recommend anybody you can
find it online read it for yourself uh
Mike Flynn
that is exculpatory evidence that is
evidence he's not a Russian agent that
is evidence that you you were right to
you should have closed the investigation
not what they ended up doing which is
saying this is evidence to keep the
investigation open and ultimately
because the Mueller you know you could
this is the thing is that once a
prosecutor kind of has you you know in
their crosshairs they can get you to
agree to something in order that you
won't have to roll the dice and go to
trial for something else and maybe go
away and they threatened his son and he
he agreed to
um you know these misstatements and so
forth and then he withdrew his his plea
agreement and ultimately the Trump
Administration correctly the justice
department correctly after by the way an
independent review people get this wrong
it wasn't Bill Barr looked at it and
said he said I would like someone
neutral so he gave it to another U.S
attorney
um I think he was representing like
Missouri at the time or something to
look at it he looked at it and
recommended okay you need to withdraw
these charges these were completely
unfair I wrote a big piece for
commentary about it it's another
um just injustice in this entire
investigation now since then
Mike Flynn has said things about the
2020 election which are absolutely
horrible and nobody should you know
they're terrible it's he's forwarded
this and it's it's utter insanity and
it's it's really Sinister
um because it it erodes confidence in
our peaceful transfer of power but then
that gets to this other point the FBI
interfered in the peaceful transfer of
our power after a free and fair election
it's a disgrace yeah and yet it seems
like there's a segment of our country
that wants to put up these leaders and
praise them as Heroes of some sort of
resistance well there's there's an
interesting and it's it's not quite
symmetrical uh but you know the right
does not want to or Republicans
conservatives don't want to concede
certain elections people like Carrie
Lake are still carrying Donald Trump is
carrying on uh but then there's a
version of that on the left and it's you
know these aren't exactly the same thing
but it's disturbing and fascinating and
it certainly is bad for the country when
you have the two major parties filled
with people who refuse to admit when
they've lost elections and that seems to
be part of the you know of the common
language right now uh Zach do you want
to yeah I'm curious you know to that uh
Bill building on that point
um the way that Trump himself has
reacted to the Durham report is worth
talking about a little bit I think
because he has a certain manner that he
likes to frame things we all remember
you know hoax uh Witch Hunt crime of the
century or the the terms that he
generally throws out there and he was
recently on Dan bongino's show reacting
to the uh Durham report so let's just
play that clip and I'm curious to hear
your thoughts Eli as to what Trump had
to say this was a coup and if I didn't
fire yes tell me probably you wouldn't
have made it I wouldn't have made it
this great Administration that did so
much wouldn't have made it because Comey
this was a whole coup they were ready to
go in if I didn't fire Comey he would
have walked in with struck and Paige and
this one and McCabe
there was a sir I'm sorry but the Russia
thing I said what Russia thing can you
imagine if you would have been taken out
of office for something that you never
even heard about these are bad people
these are sick people
was this uh an attempted coup
uh you know that's over the top
I don't like I mean I it's not a coup in
the sense if there wasn't like a general
who
you know got a group of officers to
storm the White House but it was
certainly
uh an outrageous kind of interference
as I said in the in the in the
transition uh in the presidential
transition
uh the FBI leadership's actions I mean
remember in March of 2017 again the FBI
has zero evidence at this point Comey
tells the house intelligence committee
there's an ongoing investigation a
tormentous campaign having to deal with
Russia confirming by the way stories
that were already leaked to the New York
Times in the Washington Post and
everybody else
why would he do that
he mentions the investigation in 2016
initially in July in order to say he's
not charging Clinton also highly unusual
but why would he then bring up this in
an open-ended investigation when again
the FBI had nothing with the exception
of the Steele dossier which was
disinformation so and the FBI by the way
at that point knew that danchenko was
walking away from it you can go through
the list of all the problems they
offered steel a million dollars we could
corroborate and he couldn't
so all of that information is somewhere
the CIA looked at it and said they
thought it was junk and shouldn't be
included in the intelligence assessment
so it's Comey out there who then says I
need to confirm this and everything like
that and by the way it was such a moment
such a Watergate like you know West Wing
drama moment the FBI director is
announcing an ongoing investigation into
the sitting president holy Tahiti and it
confirmed so many of the priors of
people who still bitter about the the
you know Trump winning that election
that we've sort of stopped and and and
we didn't really capture like or examine
like what what the hell is the FBI
director doing yeah why would he make
that announcement and now we know there
was no reason for him to make that
announcement we now know that that that
what he said was I mean why would you
say that that it should have pretty much
been closed at that point so
um I wouldn't call it a coup but I don't
have much sympathy and even though at
the time you know Trump couldn't have
screwed up more about how he ended up
how he fired Comey and bragging to you
know the Russian Ambassador the Russian
foreign minister in the white house the
next day about how he was crazy and
everything like that all really that was
bad but probably one of the best things
that Trump didn't it was getting rid of
Jim Comey so in the time that we have
left let's talk about the FBI and how we
go about that and then how we deal with
this larger question of things of like
how do we rebuild trust and confidence
not just in the FBI but in the political
process or in our culture and just as uh
to tee that off the uh uh The Listener
or the the viewer Colin uh for five
dollars which you can do at YouTube you
can pay money and we'll always read your
question but he writes we know the FBI
is corrupt and doj is controlled by
Biden why do we expect anything to
change Congress won't gut the entire
federal government uh Eli can you or is
uh can we look at what Durham you had
mentioned this before
Durham does not come up with
um a um a series of reforms uh Zach do
we have some language about what Durham
you know what he does kind of suggests
yes in terms of reform for the uh
he ultimately suggests uh appointing a
um career position for a non-partisan
FBI agent or lawyer to challenge fisa
applications and every other stage of
any investigation where it's a
politically
sensitive investigation so that that's
the one recommendation that he makes we
also have uh you know an appetite among
Republicans this is uh representative
Andy Biggs of Arizona who's on the house
Judiciary Committee saying defund and
dismantle the FBI which um honestly I'm
open-minded to uh just a wholesale like
do we need to is this agency even
working at all anymore but I'm curious
what you think of and we'll also point
out that Vivek ramaswamy who we
interviewed a couple weeks ago was
saying that he said that you know the
FBI should just be dismantled because it
is too far gone and rebuilt from the
ground up what that means but yeah Eli
what what should happen specifically to
the FBI in order to make it less prone
to this kind of behavior uh and other
types of system recurring mistakes it
seems well the first thing is I think
you separate the domestic intelligence
function from the FBI from the law
enforcement function so I would take out
all the intelligence stuff
that what that's in the FBI it's a big
part of the FBI it's like Hoover build
all that stuff in the 20th century
against the Communist party and the
Soviets it should go to something else
um maybe a new agency
um but it should not be under the same
roof as the cops cops and spies should
not co-exist because spies break laws
and rules and cops enforce them so as a
very basic point we do not want the same
people who are responsible for sort of
uh countering intelligence threats or uh
spying on potential terrorist cells
in the same building as the people who
are just there to you know catch
fraudsters and stuff like that and how
did 9 11 how did the response to 911
including you know the Patriot Act but
not limited to that how did that
um you know did that uh steroid up uh
Jagger Hoover's initial conception of
the intelligence gathering uh you know
an infiltration aspects of the FBI or
you know
that's a great it's a great point
um so in in a piece I wrote a few months
back for commentary magazine
um you know Kent can can the X there it
is can the FBI be saved from itself and
can we be saved from the FBI
um I get into the fact that I think it's
been missing is that right before 9 11
the FBI uh came very close to kind of
having the sorts of huge reforms that it
so desperately needs but it got out of
that because
um Louis free who was the director
um resigned in shame after uh Robert
Hansen was caught who went undetected
for 20 years as a originally a Soviet
agent and then a Russian agent and they
sort of went after it's nice to see
somebody who made a smooth transition
from the Soviet to the Russians it's
always sad that he was an American FBI
agent right
um so that was a huge blow but there
were several other things the wenho Lee
case was completely botched they ended
up could you briefly describe what the
Wen Ho Lee case because that was
something that was everywhere for a
while and then it disappeared and it is
a disturbing you know ins of you know
personification of when the FBI gets
something really wrong yeah sure I mean
this is a guy who worked for one of the
top secret doe nuclear labs and he was
accused of being a spy for the Chinese
and the FBI was absolutely convinced of
that there were a number of you know
there were a number of cases you know
stories that were written I think in in
major elite Publications like New York
Times accusing him of such and then it
ended up that they were totally wrong
and he sued the FBI and won because uh
they defamed him and even though I think
they eventually charged him with
something far less than you know I was
like taking a uh yeah a classifier a
secured computer home or something like
that yeah but it was like it was far
less than whatever yeah right but then
that's then there's like you know the
screw up
uh at Waco I mean there's all kinds of
things that happen in the 1990s that
really were very bad for the FBI and
it's traditional friends on the Capitol
Hill
um usually Republicans like the FBI so
Chuck Grassley at the time you know kind
of gives a speech about it was only in
his 80s so he was you know oddly a young
spry you know spring chicken
um was uh you know I mean like to say
hey my daddy loved the FBI but I at this
point don't think I can trust them and
that was in 19 that was in 20 that was
in like 2000 you know or 2001 when he
said that and it's only kind of gotten
worse so what happened is so Free's gone
and then Bob Mueller comes in to be the
FBI director so once you have a new guy
you're not going to blame him for
everything else and then
the FBI is kind of blamed for not
putting connecting the dots on 911.
again though that's that's Louis freeze
fault it's not Bob Mueller's fault he he
was only there like a week or two before
9 11 is his first day
um
and so the problem what they said was
that there were too many restrictions
and this is very important that FB to to
the to the fisa the the foreign
intelligence surveillance Act
um and that's the system that the FBI
uses to try to get the court to issue a
warrant to spy on American citizens
and so they needed to remove those
restrictions and knock down this wall
between collecting intelligence and
doing the law enforcement work and which
is what they they thought that was the
problem
um what's rarely mentioned is that
before 9 11 there were these fisa
scandals which
you know produced all this outrage the
fisa Court rebuked members of the F you
know for basically the same kind of
thing that we saw with Carter page FBI
agents just totally making false BS
statements to the court they were
ignoring this time limits on various
surveillance warrants so they're
continuing to listen to lines when they
shouldn't have or even in some cases
they would continue to collect
information on phones after the number
had gone to somebody else I mean all
kinds of things like this that were
violations of like what they were
supposed to do and violations of the of
of the Court oversight
it looked really bad for a while it was
the reason why we have something that's
called the woods procedure which is that
now allegedly for every fisa warrant
that you submit to the court you have to
have a separate file at FBI that shows
why every fact in that application
documented is accurate so you have to
have it's a sort of a another one of
these safeguards another one of these
reforms but what did we learn from
Horowitz what we learned from Horowitz
is that the FBI ignores the woods
procedures all the time and that gets
back to the main point of Doran which is
that if you have an institution that's
filled with people
who who aren't who don't have integrity
then you can have all the reforms you
want it's not going to make a difference
so there has to be something that is
also in addition to I think removing the
intelligence collection from the bureau
which is a no-brainer
I mean this is going to sound strange
because normally I don't like the idea
I'm I'm like you reason magazine and
many others and I'm very aware I don't
like cancel culture
but James Comey and Andrew McCabe and
Peter strzok and Lisa Page need to be
canceled that I don't want to send them
to jail but I think they need to be
canceled I think they need to be kind of
like you know banished from polite
Society they should not be asked to you
know appear on prestigious Think Tank
panels or to teach at universities or to
appear as law enforcement analysts on
CNN and something like that would show
that there are at least some sort of
social consequences for
FBI leaders who have fallen so far of
the mark and have been have been so have
lacked so much integrity and then maybe
we have a chance at sort of trying to
change what appears to be a really I'm
worried about the culture of the FBI at
this point because it's not limited to
just I mean listen this is an egregious
case but we see it time and again
um that oftentimes these G-Men kind of
think there's a law unto themselves and
we can't have that so I I'd like to see
some some social consequences for some
of these folks I think another important
aspect to point out here is that with
the fisa courts being you know one of
the main Avenues of abuse in this case
and many other cases there was an
opportunity during the Trump
Administration to push for reform to the
fisa ACT and that was on the table Trump
did not get behind that there were some
some libertarian leaning Republicans who
were very much in favor of it Trump you
know pretty much rubber stamped that
going through so at the top you need
someone who's serious about actually
reining in these excesses and also some
sort of recognition if the part of the
answer is to somehow separate say the
law enforcement aspect law enforcement
from intelligence and not mingle them so
much in one like giant blob
everything has been going in the
opposite direction since 9 11 as you
point out because in that commentary
piece you know you make you make the
very uh astute point that
the F even though the FBI was somewhat
blamed for intelligence failures there
the result was you know they were
rewarded more power so these agencies
going uh in the wrong direction when
these failures happen and I don't know
how you kind of flip the script on that
but uh that that seems like an important
aspect of turning this around yeah can I
ask is there you know is there an
appetite for reform and you know think
about like we talk about the fisa courts
as if you know we don't even think about
it anymore but that the whole fisa
system was a response to uh
investigations in the mid 70s widespread
investigations that were horrifying that
showed that the NSA the CIA and the FBI
were just completely uninterested in
limits on their power and we're engaged
in all kinds of illegal surveillance and
activity and whatnot so you get the fisa
courts then they become the the Avenue
of abuse to do more of that you get 911
uh which then says okay you know what we
got to give them more power and less
oversight in a profound way uh and now
we have you know russiagate which at
least in the news media and throughout
it seems like many in the Democratic
party are saying you know what the what
russiagate shows is that we need you
know it it's not that our internal
investigation apparatuses are completely
corrupt or false or dumb they need more
power because Trump got elected and he
was colluding with Russia you know so
it's like it's a self
um kind of sustaining operation to just
give more power to surveillance in the
name of a free society which is
disturbing but I wonder if we do get to
a pointer or um Eli could you talk about
what is that point where the the script
starts to flip I'm talking to you from
LA and I was driving around in the
Showtime series
um uh with Michael Shanahan about Waco
the second season is coming out you know
there was a version of this couple uh
years ago Waco is you know one of those
major scandals in the 90s that showed
the FBI was not very good at what it you
know what it is always lionized for you
know all of the public relations you
know the FBI there was a long-running TV
show everything you hear about the fbis
the you know the G-men are the goddamn
[__] best people in the world you
know they they are upright they are Boy
Scouts they are straight hours and they
are really really good at what they do
and what we learn you know and again
through Beverly Gage's uh uh new
biography of Jagger Hoover Uh Tim
Weiner's enemies that came out a few
years ago when we're Louis free you know
he says Jagger Hoover was terrible and
he's by far from the worst FBI director
of all time it's really Louis Fray
um you know is there wow it's how you
imagine are terrible I know I know
you're talking about with wiener but
it's it's a little bit of a yeah I'm
just saying like what what are the
accumulations are you know and is it is
it Scandal is it cultural production is
it
um you know serious people in Congress
because there is a group of right-wing
you know or people on the right uh some
of them are Libertarians who are
actually principled and not just
partisan hacks people on the left who
are like you know what the hell is going
on like our intelligence agencies not
only they fail to protect us but then
they are constantly breaking the law as
well so that you know what what has to
happen to trigger a real uh serious uh
set of reforms
well I think one thing that needs to
happen is that there needs to be a kind
of uh you know uh and I have mixed
feelings about it because I'm centered
right in my overall politics but there
needs to be some sort of like revolution
in the Democratic party I mean I think
it's an anomaly that only can happen
right now where if because Trump's the
leader of the Republicans then it means
that you can have a cast of people at
the top of the democratic party not and
I'm including Joe Biden but not just
Biden to people like Adam Schiffer
um it's now like the sort of leadership
of the democratic party you know their
their sensors they they love the FBI and
the National Security State
um and
um they seem to have no compunction
about turning these things against their
political adversaries whether it's
uh social media companies through
pressure from Congress or by claiming
that everybody who you know has you know
I mean listen I I don't question the
validity of the 2020 election but if
there are Americans who might have
questions about it because it was an
unusual year in the middle of a pandemic
and there were all these new procedures
it doesn't make them a so-called
insurrectionist or a Russian agent and
anyway these attitudes at the top of the
democratic party and I'm not I have lots
of problems with the Republican party
and lots of problems with Trump and we
can talk about that too those people
need to be
um ousted from their positions of power
they need to and there is a struggle
there can be other people people like
rokana are aware of some of the free
speech problems and he needs to be
strengthened even though I'm sure I will
have huge disagreements with rocana when
it comes to
the regular regulatory state or foreign
policy I I'm I'm acknowledging that I
don't agree with a lot of the other more
Progressive wing of the Democrats but I
would rather them at this point than
this nanny State censorship crew
um that are just a bunch of Hypocrites
and
um obsessed with this idea of
disinformation which is so arrogant and
it's so anti-democratic to think that
Americans are incapable of judging
information on their own and so they're
gonna they're it's like their minds are
gonna be poisoned or something like that
whereas these people's minds appear to
be poisoned by this lunatic collusion
conspiracy
um so it's very frustrating and I think
those people really need to go and then
you know you'll see it's like it's like
a Tipping Point I mean if there's a
Tipping Point where is there is there a
gerontocracy problem here as well
because you know when you think of Biden
and you think of Dianne Feinstein and
you think of you know many of the older
people in Congress and and we're talking
very old but you know they have a
different you know they forgot the
lessons of the 70s really oh they did
they clear and it's it's ironic
because she was the victim of uh
domestic terrorism yeah and she becomes
the mayor of San Francisco because of
the assassination of Harvey Milk I guess
right or right uh no of uh uh Moscone
yeah exactly right right so but so she
was always like a hawkish democrat in
the middle but like you know Biden was
in the senate for the church committee
um and Biden you know and and by the way
the Democratic party under George W bush
it's not that long ago were raising
questions about warrantless surveillance
in the NSA and Stellar Wind program and
but then you had the flip under Obama
right where Obama I mean partly gets
elected by saying I'm going to have the
most transparent Administration we're
not going to illegally surveil people
and then when Edward stone is like hey
what about all this stuff Obama's
response which was politically brilliant
he was like you know I am I'm really
interested in having a conversation
about unwarranted you know our illegal
surveillance or ubiquity of all of this
stuff but he didn't act that way and it
kind of hardened it seemed to have
hardened liberals I don't think
progressives but liberals to be like oh
you know what the Deep State I mean the
Deep state is what kept us from having
Donald Trump you know as president or
something so well I mean right but yeah
I mean but um just in the you know last
couple of minutes we're gonna we're
gonna stop but I guess you know can we
talk a little bit about how the decline
and trust and Authority uh in
institutions generally uh in political
institutions in particular I'm just
looking at Gallup in
1975 uh they have a a general index of
trust and confidence in major
institutions in America it was at 48 of
people had a great deal or a good deal
of confidence and Trust in institutions
it's down to 27 now in this is amazing
to me in 1975 Gallup 52 of Americans had
a great deal or a good deal of trust and
confidence in the presidency as an
institution it is now at 23
um so you know the the recognition that
the FBI and kind of the broader
intelligence community and law
enforcement community in America is you
know is not what it seems to be is part
of a yeah you know I'll say two things
about it one is that it's it's in you
know it's a concession to reality
everything that we learn about this it's
like yeah we shouldn't have as much
confidence and trust in these things
um and it's also you know that what's
going on with the FBI
um you know and and I think what comes
out of the dura report and everything is
part and parcel of a larger
downward trend for the past 50 or 60
years
um how do we you know you've talked a
little bit about how the FBI like how we
might change that around et cetera like
how do we how do we build back these
trusts and confidence in institutions so
that we are not becoming you know
weirdly again given that the way Russia
discussions of Russia influence all of
this but that we don't become the kind
of low trust society that Russia is
which then you know it doesn't mean
people give up on government and stop
funding and it really means that
governments can get away with anything
because people are expecting the worst
well that's certainly true I mean one
thing I would say is that you know at
the time uh
I don't think we noticed it but you know
Obama used to say this had this
catchphrase that um used to call it the
false choice between Liberty and
security or Freedom insecurity
um it's not a false choice
and maybe one way to begin to restore
trust is for government leaders to
Simply say this if you want us to
protect you from every possible
terrorist attract
then you're going to have to accept that
some of your private privacy and some of
your some of some of your uh some of
your rights that you've you know you
sort of take for granted are going to be
infringed upon and that we are going to
have a sort of you know panopticon
monitor State uh if you if you need us
to protect and prevent every terrorist
attack or something like that if you
don't think if you think that it's more
important to live with you know with you
know some separation and you don't want
the government to be that powerful
I think I would now I would be on that
side then you're after accept that
there's going to be some risk and some
bad things are going to are going to
happen and it's not the fault of our
government it's because we made a
conscious choice that we do not want the
kind of awesome power that would be
required to prevent future terrorist
attacks so that's one area where I do
think after 9 11
there was something that happened where
we just sort of American the American
people just sort of said no like you no
more not again and I get I understand
that after 9 11 I lived through it but
the implication of that was
uh this huge expansion of the National
Security State and empowering the FBI to
do all kinds of things now first it was
against the Muslim Community in America
and we didn't really like I'm sadly I we
weren't as attuned to that that there
were American citizens who clearly had
their rights you know violated in a lot
of the way that the FBI approached this
sort of approach to preventing you know
future terrorist attacks
but now we're seeing that that same
approach is done against domestic
extremists on the right and other people
like that and when you start looking at
it you're like wait a second
you know this why is the SWAT team going
to some guy's house because he's a
pro-life activist or something like that
and that that happens
um and you know can the FBI get away
with this sort of thing
and if you're if you're upset about that
and I would hope a lot of Americans are
upset about that then you we should be
realistic about it and say all right
well wait it's unrealistic to expect our
government to prevent all of these kinds
of attacks we're gonna have to live with
a level of risk
Zach uh final thought yeah or a question
for you live yeah and I I know I'm also
on that side of the uh equation if those
are the two choices I'll take a little
bit you're objectively pro-terrorism
that's what that's what I'm getting
um but you know I wonder you know as
this comes this is kind of like a the
closing of a chapter or something like
we've had the Mueller report the the
Durham report and that it feels like
kind of like the final government's word
on this at least but the the report for
getting something Jack when they finally
declassify
the five percent of the Mueller report
which is Still Remains classified then
we're going to have proof of collusion
yeah yeah and you know well yeah
Marshall of the Supreme Court will will
will follow the execution orders for
Steve Bannon and all these other you
know well so that's that's kind of like
the point I I want to get to get that is
that there's always going to be this
sort of you know remainder I guess that
still like holds on to it and you
mentioned earlier like you're never
gonna convince David from that the
Russia gate is more or less like a a
made-up thing
um but what are given that that belief
is still just gonna linger out there
what are the lasting effects of the
russiagate narrative on our politics and
our culture and Society well for one I
think it has
it's like a little bit of a temporary
Lifeline to the FBI which should be
reeling from Scandal right now
um but it won't be reeling from Scandal
because
the leadership of one of our major
parties that controls the presidency
um will defend it precisely because it's
you know the other side that is so
exercising about it so it so so the the
sort of
I don't know the the uh the lingering of
this disinformation
uh has the effect of blunting and
stopping reform and I think the other
thing is is that it further just it I
think it it it kind of further just
intensifies the distrust between
citizens and between our political
parties
um and it makes it really difficult to
be in the place where I am and I imagine
the two of you are which is that I don't
like Trump I think Trump's a dangerous
demagogue I think there's a lot of bad
things about him yeah but I also don't
like the these abuses that have been
uncovered about the FBI and so if in
order to you know it's like I don't have
I don't I don't feel like I need to
choose between those two things I can
have both of those positions but for a
lot of Americans in the loudest voices
in our discourse it's you have to what
you have to choose between the two and
you know so so that's a huge problem in
that it's I think it it really kind of
stupefies us it makes us Dumber
and I wish I wish it wasn't the case but
that's where we are
all right well we are gonna leave it
there that's where we are at the reason
live stream which uh please come back
next Thursday at 1 pm eastern time we
have been talking with Eli Lake who is
who's brilliant podcast the re-education
is available everywhere I tend to listen
to it on Spotify but it's on Apple it's
Etc you also write regularly for
commentary uh you just had a big piece
of the Free Press
yeah so uh you just Google Eli Lake and
uh put safe search on you know yeah
adult performer but uh read the articles
don't look at the pictures for real I
like uh free Johnson Claire okay yeah
thank you uh so much uh wonderful
talking to you and thank you really
appreciate the work that you're doing
Zach wisemiller as always uh we will be
here next week uh next Thursday Zach
what are you working on just to give
people a taste Zach has emerged over the
past decade really but certainly over
the past few years as the documentarian
in Chief I think of Reason uh TV
um you did well you did a couple of
weeks ago you did a great piece about
homelessness in in San Francisco versus
Texas or California versus Texas which
is brilliant quarter of a million views
deserves twice as much as that what are
you working on these uh thanks and yeah
that was a collaboration with uh Liz
Wolfe and there's a lot of great
documentaries coming out from many
people on the platform uh what we've
most recently uh our most recent trip
was to Miami where the latest bit coin
conference was taking place and so we're
going to give a kind of like what is
bitcoin at this point like what does it
mean what is this the culture that has
emerged around it I think it's going to
be
um a really interesting piece and I'll
also just take a moment to promote a uh
a documentary we made earlier this year
about a Supreme Court case that was just
decided today uh pertaining to the EPA
and the way that it regulates waterways
um that is a very important decision
that just came out and we have an
in-depth documentary about that case
which has been going on for over a
decade at this point so those are what I
would point to people too okay and then
I'm just going to make a quick plug for
myself uh for reason in New York City if
you live in New York City on Monday June
5th uh you know a week and a half we're
doing a live taping of the reason
interview podcast in Midtown at the blue
building which is the coolest building
in Manhattan patent on a bizarre block
that's just down the streets from a
famous steakhouse where a famous mobster
was rubbed out it is unlike any place
you've ever seen in Manhattan but I'm
interviewing cat 10th the Fox News
contributor Gutfeld regular who has a
great new book out called uh you can't
joke about that
um go to reason.com events to see what
we're doing we're popping up all over
the place and it's if you like what we
do online uh it's even better in person
but thank you again Eli Lake of the
re-education Zach wisemiller of reason
and I'm Nick Gillespie we'll see you
next week